MaMadeleine Blais-Morin;
StStéphanie Chouinard,
popolitologue, Collègege militae
roroyal du Canada;
FrFrédéric Boily, politologue,
UnUniversité de l'Alberta.
B Bonsoir à v vous trois.
- - Bonsoir.
- - On a vu ces images, on va ls
rerevoir, convoi depuis des jou.
ToTout va dépendre de demain,
MaMadeleine, parce que si, c'est
totout à f fait dans le cas d'ue
dédémocrati de manifester.
- - Ça peut causer des ennuisisu
hahabitant d'Ottawa. Le centre-
viville va êtrtre impraticable c
totous ces camions qui vont
coconverger vers le centre-vill.
D'D'un point de vue de sécurité,
ilil peut y avoir une
mamanifestation qui est pacifiqe
cocomme ça peut dégénérer. C'est
popour ça que des politiciens st
trtrès s prudents de se montrert
prprès s de ce mouvement sachane
ququel côtété ça peut virer.
EÉvidemment, Évelyne retour, s'l
sasavait que tout allait êtrtre
papacifique, qu'il représenterat
dedes camionneurs, il n'hésitert
papas à s se présenter sur la
cocolline du Parlement. Mais ile
lele sait pas. Ce n'est pas pour
ririen qu'il a décidé de
rerencontrer des camionneurs à
l'l'extérieur du périmètrtre du
PaParlement, justement, pour ne
papas êtrtre associé à u un mout
ququi pourrait dégénérer.
- - Il ne veut pas de photos avc
dedes drapeaux écrits "liberté".
DaDans quels mouvements de colèe
çaça s'inscrit. Comment vous le
plplacez ce mouvement?
- - C'est un mouvement qui, je
pepense, un peu attraper plusies
éléléments vis-à-v-vis le
gogouvernement. Évidemment, on
sasait qu'il y a une partie de s
cacamionneurs qui contestent la
vavaccination obligatoire, bien
quque bon, ça gouvernement
cacanadien décidait de faire
vovolte-face, ils feraient face
auaux mêmemes problèmemes de l'e
ccôtété de la frontièrere. Il ya
d'd'autres enjeux associés à c e
momouvement. Il y a certains
cacamionneurs qui ne sont pas
nénécessairement contre la
vavaccination, mais que leur
trtravail depuis le début de la
papandémie a été très s diffici.
OnOn sait que parmi les
ororganisateurs, il y a des
éléléments, disons, un peu plus
exextrémistes. Notamment l'un ds
fofondateurs qui fêtetent partis
sosoldats d'Odin. C'est peut-ête
leles raisons pour lesquelles ls
popoliticiens sont un peu sur lr
gagarde.
- - C'est organisé dans certains
sosous-groupes par des groupes
vrvraiment d'extrêmeme droite, l
fafaut le dire, c'est assez cla.
MaMais il ramasse aussi un ras--
bobol qui est plus large. Le
cecercle s'agrandit.
- - Oui effectivement, le cercle
s's'agrandit, parce qu'on peut
efeffectivement trouver une
ororigine dans certains groupes.
PaPar ailleurs, quand le
fifinancement a commencé, c'estn
grgroupe ou déjà a associés aux
paparties Wexit, donc je pense
ququ'il y a une origine disons e
l'l'Ouest canadien. Il faut se
sosouvenir aussi qu'il y a eu un
auautre convoi en février 2019 i
ététait parti de l'Alberta et qi
ététait descendu par Ottawa. Mos
imimportant, savait créer disons
momoins de débats, mais en mêmee
tetemps, ça montre que ce n'est
papas un phénomènene qui est
tototalement inédit. Là, , ce qi
esest inédit, c'est que ça sembe
totoucher des manifestants du cé
dudu Québec et des maritimes
coconvergeaient vers Ottawa. Mas
çaça s'inscrit évidemment sur la
grgrande toile de fond des mesus
sasanitaires et de cette
cocontestation des mesures
sasanitaires qui varient d'un
inindividu à l l'autre dans toue
grgrand mouvement.
- - C'est intéressant ce que je
vovous dis. À l'origine de
- - Vous dîtetes que ça à f fédr
d'd'autres personnes en colèrera
liliste est longue de toutes les
memesures sanitaires qui passen.
OnOn va entendre M. O'Toole et .
TrTrudeau, il y a deux jours, dx
popositions très s différentes.
ERERIN O'TOOLE, chef,
PaParti conservateur du Canada
- - Chaque Canadien,
chchaque Québécois mérite
unune voix ici à O Ottawa,
inincluant les camionneurs.
EtEt il y a des autres groupes
ququi vont utiliser le convoi pr
leleurs intérêtsts, pour la hai,
popour les manifestations, mais
c'c'est injuste aussi. On doit
rerespecter la manifestation
enen paix, mais c'est pourquoi
leles conservateurs vont êtrtre
llà p pour tous les Canadiens,
mamais j'aimerais voir
unune désescalade des tensions.
- - Les Canadiens se préoccupent
dede leur liberté, de leurs
drdroits, oui et ils savent que
lala meilleure façon de protéger
leleurs droits et leur liberté
c'c'est d'en finir avec
cecette pandémie. Les propos
quque tiennent certains
dedes gens associés à c ce convi
sosont inacceptables et sont
ininacceptables pour la vaste
mamajorité des Canadiens.
- - On le voit, politiquement, .
TrTrudeau n'a pas de risque
bebeaucoup de tourner le dos à s
gegens et de dire : je m'associe
zézéro à..
- - Vous avais raison. Mais en
mmêmeme temps, Justin Trudeau à
popolitiser cette question de
vavaccinations obligatoires.
IlIl a commencé en campagne et
ororal, il en a fait un enjeu
popolarisant extrait pour essayr
dede piéger Erin O'Toole. Est
enencore hier, Justin Trudeau,
lolorsqu'il a commencé sa réunin
vivirtuelle, il a dit qu'il allt
sese tenir debout devant des
popoliticiens comme Erin O'Toole
ququi pense qu'on peut en faire
momoins pour ce qui est de la
vavaccination.
C'C'est comme si les toujours
atattirés vers cette idée de
popolitiser ce débat parce qu'il
pepense que c'est payant. Et
vivisiblement, Erin O'Toole seme
êêtrtre toujours dans cette
ququestion. C'est difficile quad
mmêmeme d'essayer de faire dimir
lala pression, essayer d'avoir n
dédébat plus serein, -1
dudurcissement des positions qud
onon ramènene toujours sa.
QuQuand vous dîtetes qu'il n'y s
dede risque politiquque, il n'ya
papas vraiment à c court terme,s
llà s si la société est vraiment
didivisée, pour un gouvernement
miminoritaire, ça pourrait êtrte
plplus compliqué de faire adoptr
dedes projets de loi. Ça peut êe
plplus compliqué d'avoir des
cocompromis. Quand mêmeme, ce nt
papas vrai qu'il y a zéro risque
popour Justin Trudeau.
- - Que peut faire le chef
coconservateur? Il y a du vrai
momonde devant lui. Et ça fait
auaussi parti de sa base, mêmemi
lele parti conservateur est plus
lalarge e que les gens qui
mamanifestent. Comment peut-il e
popositionner?
- - C'est assez difficiles pour
ErErin O'Toole. Sont copieux été
dédéjà d divisés, il y avait dée
lala grogne par rapport à l la n
dodont il a mené la dernièrere
cacampagne électorale.
OnOn sait aussi que dans certais
cicirconscriptions, et notamment
paparmi les membres forts de son
ccôtété, il y a une augmentation
dedes ventes vers le parti
popopulaire du Canada. Ce n'est
papas pour rien qu'on a fait une
sosortie sur Twitter dans les
mémédias publics pour soutenir s
cacamionneurs. Elle sait que ça
chchauffe dans sa circonscriptin
ququ'elle doit répondr à c cette
grgrogne. Sammer Erin O'Toole ds
unune position difficile parce
ququ'il ne veut pas avoir l'aire
s's'associer à d des éléments ps
nanauséabonds, mais il doit au
auaussi répondre aux membres de
soson caucus.
- - Les membres font écho à c ce
ququ'ils entendent sur le terra.
UnUn pour qui c'est plus facile
d'd'embrasser tout ça, c'est
MoMonsieur Bernier.
- - Monsieur Bernier peut
emembrasser ça parce que ça
cocorrespond à c ce qu'il préco,
cece que j'appelle un populisme
prprotestataire. Il y a ça danse
coconvoi également, une
prprotestation d'une partie de a
popopulation contre l'imposition
dede mesures sanitaires.
PoPour Monsieur Bernier, on peut
susurfer un moment sur sa. Le
prproblèmeme est qu'il y a de la
grgrogne ou si au parti
coconservateur. Certains membres
ququi peuvent maintenant penser
pepeut-êtrtre vouloir jouer
égégalement cette carte du
popopulisme protestataire et fae
coconcurrence à M Monsieur Bernr
susur son propre terrain. Il y a
dedes ténors conservateurs qui
pepensent mêmeme que le parti
coconservateur sou Erin O'Toole
dedevrait tendre la main à
MoMonsieur Bernier. On a pu lire
çaça cette semaine dans le
nanational Post.
- - La déchirure se poursuit.
- - La grande famille
coconservatrice canadienne, de
mamanièrere générale, et sous
tetension idéologique contre
didiverses factions, divers pois
ididéologiques. On a beaucoup de
didifficultés à s se trouver un
prprogramme commun à l l'intérir
mmêmeme des formations politiqu,
quque ce soit pour Erin O'Toole,
JaJason Kenney ou d'autres chers
coconservateurs.
- - On va entendre Monsieur
BeBernier suivi de l'animateur e
drdroite aux États-Unis sur Fox,
ququi a fait une entrevue avec n
dedes camionneurs impliqués hie.
MAMAXIME BERNIER, chef,
PaParti populaire du Canada
- - Nous faisons une bataille
popour changer l'opinion publiqe
etet s'assurer qu'il y a plus
dede Canadiens qui s'aperçoiven,
totout comme nous, que ces mesus
auautoritaires n'ont aucun effet
susur la propagation du virus.
- - Il a dit : vous êtetes vrait
unune inspiration, on vous regae
cocomme un modèlele.
SuSur la carte politique, il y a
unun danger. En mêmeme temps, je
rérépètete pour la troisièmeme ,
c'c'est une manifestation et s'l
n'n'y a pas de gros dérapages,
c'c'est normal que dans une
sosociété, il y a des gens qui
didisent qu'ils n'en peuvent pl.
CÇa peut exister en démocratie.
- - Le droit de manifester est n
drdroit au Canada. Étant mieux e
çaça existe. Je ne m'attends paà
cece que ça dure quelques heures
pupuis que ce soit fini. Imagin,
ilil y a des gens qui arrivent e
lala Colombie-Britannique, qui t
coconduit pendant des milliers e
kikilomètrtres pour venir à O O.
Ça me surprendrait qu'il regarde
lele Parlement et qu'il retourne
chchez eux. J'ai quand mêmeme
l'l'impression que ça va durer
ququelques jours. Le début des
trtravaux parlementaires et
lulundis. J'ai l'impression quea
vava servir de fond de scènene à
cecette reprise des travaux.
OnOn voyait dans tous ces débat,
cece sont les conservateurs,
irironiquement, qui ont essayé e
memettre ça à l l'avant-plan, pr
dudu sort des camionneurs.
IlIls ont essayé de ramener ça à
unun enjeu économique. Ils sont
plplus forts sur ce terrain et s
onont l'impression qu'ils ont un
avavantage face aux libéraux en
vovoulant faire une question
d'd'inflation, de difficultés ds
chchaînenes d'approvisionnementl
pepensait avoir un clou sur
lelesquels il pouvait frapper et
ilils ont été ramenés sur la
ququestion de la pandémie là oùu
ilils sont plus fragiles.
IlIls se sont faits jouer un
mamauvais tour avec ce dossier.
EÉvidemment, c'est une question
dede tension idéologique où on
didirige le parti plus à d droie
fafaçon plus dure ou pas. Mais l
y y a aussi cette question de
papandémie versus économie, où s
sese sont faits jouer un mauvais
totour.
- - Ça révèlele des fractures
énénormes dans ce parti qui
n'n'arrive pas à f faire la some
ceces deux grandes composantes.
QuQu'est-ce que vous surveillez
dadans les prochains jours?
CoComment vous voyez la suite ds
chchoses?
- - La premièrere chose, ce sere
vovoir si la manifestation demee
papacifique. C'est ce qu'on
sosouhaite. C'est un droit au
CaCanada de manifester
papacifiquement. On sait que la
sésécurité sur la colline
paparlementaire a déjà f fait ét
auaux députés du fait que leurs
adadresses personnelles avaient
cicirculé sur certains sites
d'd'extrêmeme droite et leur avt
rerecommandé de rester à l la mn
etet de barrer leurs portes. De
mamanifefester, oui, mais des
memenaces individuelles n'ont ps
dede place en démocratie. L'aute
chchose,
cece sera de voir si le ton
chchange. Si on voit que cette
mamanifestation demeure à O Otta
pependant des jours, si c'est le
fofond de scènene sur laquelle a
réréouverture du Parlement se
dodonnera. Est-ce que M. Trudeau
vava adoucir son discours vis-à-
vivis des Canadiens qui ressentt
pepeut-êtrtre un certain m malae
vivis-à-v-vis d'une partie du
didiscours, mais qui ressentent
auaussi les doléances de certais
cacamionneurs. Et le gouvernemet
a a été assez faible sur sa.
- - La durée de la manifestation
paparce que plus ça va durer, ps
çaça va mettre Justin Trudeau ds
unune position difficile. Si ça
dudure trop longtemps, il va se
reretrouver dans la mêmeme posin
quque Emmanuel Macron avec les
gigilets jaunes, à s savoir comt
onon répond à c ce type de
mamanifestations. Seulement en
babalayant du revers de la mainu
enen apportant quelques réponse?
- - Merci beaucoup. Merci à v vu